[Musique]
salut septembre tu vous parle
aujourd'hui du au nord de 10 qui a été
officialisé en chine
c'est un smartphone tablette fable est
plutôt faible est qui pourrait arriver
qui pourrait arriver d'ici quelques
temps dans france en europe et dans le
reste du monde et c'est un produit et
qui en tout cas être super intéressant
qu'à plein de nouvelles fonctionnalités
qui montre vraiment là où va aller
huawei honor l'année prochaine
d'ailleurs même sur cette fin d'année
c'est plutôt cool et ça je vous en parle
maintenant
vous connaissez forcément au nord on a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup parlé on a
testé il ya pas très longtemps le gti
turbo sur le au nord 10 hélas ce qui est
super cool c'est que au nord continuent
à aller plus loin et c'est vraiment un
coup de maître avec son au nord notes 10
alors pour l'instant et a prévu de
commercialiser en europe mais en règle
générale avec au nord les premiers sont
présentés dans un premier temps en chine
et ensuite ils sont présentés en europe
en france pour la distribution
européenne à mon avis on le retrouve ici
quelques temps je vous paye présentation
avant qu'elle ne soit fait en france est
normalement si tout se passe bien ça
pourrait se passer à l'histoire parce
que j'enfile mon carton d'invitation
pour être présent un event à l'ifa au
mois de septembre par fin août début
septembre
donc je vous invite à rester connectés
comme ça on ira boire directement ça
ensemble et puis si c'est pas le 10 sera
un autre produit au nord dans tous les
cas on aura des produits qui sont
vraiment sexy surtout sur une politique
de prix vraiment vraiment pas trop cher
et ça c'est ce qui est vraiment
intéressant
je sais pas si vous savez mais au nord
signe filiale de huawei reconnaît huawei
qui monte en gamme vraiment continuer à
monter en gamme
c'est à dire que plus un pro ils ont
vraiment fait une super explosion au
nord c'est une marque destinée à un
public plutôt jeune n'est pas que est là
avec ses odeurs 9 10 et pour aller plus
loin parlant d'une hotte d'ici là un
design assez standard et est la limite
c'est tant mieux
une bordure en ou une vente durant ma
des bordures à ses films son côté pas
d'encoches un capteur d'empreinte
digitale au dos de l'appareil double
module photo également au dos à la
verticale vous avez vos deux petits
modules de séparer la verticale une
seule caméra à l'avant assez classique
plutôt pas mal réussi là où l'honneur
note 10 bat des records c'est sur son
écran amoled de 6,95 pouces c'est à dire
quand même un super grand écran là où on
a des smartphones de 6 pouces 6,2 pouces
6,95 pouces c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment énorme
du coup sa classe directement sur l'eau
dce dans la catégorie des fables est il
une définition full aviez plus un ratio
18,5 9e et il est compatible hd r10 en
cas pas délaissé qui est super
intéressant c'est les haut parleurs
stéréo vous avez un haut parleur de
chaque côté qui supporte le dolby atmos
ça c'est super pour les expériences de
jeu lorsque vous voulez vous faire
plaisir ce que voulait jouer parce que
vraiment vous allez voir la puissance
s'agit vous l'expliquer d'ici quelques
temps pour les expériences de jeu c'est
beaucoup plus immersive
lorsque vous arrivez des vidéos celle
légalement et ça pour le coup c'est
aussi une des réussites
alors côté puissance c'est justement là
où c'est intéressant on a un socle kirin
970 couple soit assise giga de ram soit
à 8 gigas de ram et là où c'est
intéressant c'est qu'il est un système
de refroidissement liquide qui s'appelle
the nine ça fonctionne un peu comme le
système de refroidissement sur les pc
portables et ça vous permet de refroidir
votre machine de l'ordre de 40% soit à
peu près 10 degrés en utilisation
intensive parce que l'utilisation
intensive c'est un petit peu ce qu'on
recherche un peu la donne de ce produit
vous avez gpu turbo aux événements comme
son turbo au niveau cpu haut niveau gpu
vous avez un bouton pour l'activer comme
ça lorsque vous avez vraiment besoin de
puissance vous pouvez d'ailleurs
forcément ça ne répond pas un peu plus
de batterie mais de ce côté-là aussi
soyez tranquilles parce que vous avez
une batterie de 5 millions perreur macri
hyper massive comme ça vous aurez le
temps de voir venir alors souhaité
isation petit peu standard un petit peu
lambda je dirais pour une initiation
tous les jours soit du réseau sociaux
des emails surfer sur internet par et
des vidéos une batterie de salemi
l'intérieur vous avoir une autonomie de
dingue dès lors vous voulez de la
puissance si vous allez jouer sur des
jeux qui sont un petit peu plus gourmand
vous activez la fonction turbo la
batterie il va encaisser tout ça il va
se refroidir complètement grâce au
refroidissement liquide avec the nine et
là c'est une belle de complète à noter
que vous avez également une puce qui
dédiée à l'intelligence artificielle ça
va vraiment vous servir pour la photo et
pour la vidéo la reconnaissance de sel
dans pleins d'utilisation bien
évidemment c'est ce produit qui est
présenté à l'ifa fin août début
septembre
on va les prendre en main on va le
tester puis après on testera plus en
détails comme ça je pourrais vous dire
réellement moi ce que j'en pense si il
me paraît intéressant est vraiment
acquise des sites mais très clairement
on déjà rien qu'au niveau de la fiche
technique on voit qu'on destine à un
public gamer alors je sais vous allez me
dire gamer sur les gamers forcément là
dessus mais de plus en plus de personnes
vont jouer sur des smartphones il y en a
chez asus chez xiaomi chez razer et
honore carrément une politique destinée
à un public plus jeune et notamment au
gamer continue à monter en puissance
avec des smartphones comme le note 10
côté photo vidéo vous avez à l'arrière
un double module photo 16 mégapixels en
couleur 24 mégapixels monochrome ouvrant
à f 1.8 à l'avant vous
d un simple capteur photo 13 mégapixels
avec une ouverture de f 2.0
et tout ça optimisée grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle il tourne
sous android
8.1 oreo la surcouche le n 8 points 2 il
est dispo en noir et en bleu et vous
avez trois configurations possibles soit
6 giga de ram 64 giga de stockage qui
devrait disponible aux alentours des 3
149 euros hors taxe soit 6 giga de ram
128 go de stockage au tarif oscillant
aux alentours des 4 100 euros soit 8
gigas de ram et 128 go de stockage à un
tarif avoisinant les 4 149 euros tout ça
hors taxe et il est dispo dès le 1er
août en chine si vous habitez en chine
vous pouvez toujours le commander sinon
pour l'europe
il va falloir attendre un petit peu
prendre votre mal en patience toujours
est il que ce produit on en reparlera
très très très très très prochainement
dans invite à faire une chose c'est à
vous abonner à rester connectés parce
que on va aller voir au nord directement
à l'ifa on valoir plein d'autres mâles
majorque plein de choses super
intéressantes que ce soit sur
l'ordinateur portable se sont dits
smartphones de la tablette de la photo
la vidéo par ailleurs énormément de
choses dont je vous invite à vous
abonner à rester connectés comme d'hab
abcd jolie plus à marquer toutes vos
questions suggestions interrogations
directement commentaires que je lis très
bientôt ce message vous allez voir et
voir plein de nouveautés à la rentrée je
travaille à fond afin guinée tout mon
corps tout mon temps devant nous pour
nous concocter un format toujours plus
intéressant à partir du mois de
septembre
d'ici là soyez sages sportez vous bien
et à de maintes 1
[Musique]